we've been hearing harrowing stories
from people who made it out after
Hurricane durian flattened parts of the
Bahamas well two Americans were stranded
there losing contact with their husbands
and the middle of the storm Nicki
Bateses in Nassau the Bahamian capital
Nikki this sounds extremely scary yes it
is dareka good morning Pam and Joanne
tell us they were rescued and flown home
to Florida yesterday but when the
hurricane hit they were on the phone
with their husbands back in the US when
their screens went black and for the
next 48 hours their husbands feared the
worst
we were terrified they saw us being
terrified and they saw all connection
with us completely good black Pam mably
and Joanne Coakley were facetiming with
their husbands back home when hurricane
durian struck while they were on
vacation
the walls were literally pulsing the
house was alive like this it was just
the and we were underneath the table and
then we were in a bathtub and then we
were in a closet and we were absolutely
terrified the two best friends couldn't
get in touch with their family for
another 48 hours and we knew they
thought we were dead and that was
probably the worst part for me at home
their husbands were glued to the
television for 20 hours a day
desperately looking for answers the last
visualization we had was a house coming
down on our wife so I mean that's when
panic mode was meanwhile Joanne and Pam
who is a physician went out in the
middle of the hurricane to help treat
anyone who was injured it was just a
house but and I have a home to go back
to but the people in green turtle they
don't and it's gonna be years before
they're comfortable again some residents
entire families were rescued like
one-year-old rein and her mother Asti
Nadine kept me going was the child that
was it I looked at her and I was like no
my baby's not going out like this
58 year old Isaiah had debris-filled
water up to his neck and held on to a
piece of wood trying to survive
very very thankful to be alive to tell
my story because I don't have men who
are not allowed to talk about it
Pam's husband told us this experience
reminded him it's not material things
that matter and it's time to focus on
what's most important family Pam says
she wants to come back here to the
Bahamas to help once she's regrouped
Anthony all right Nikki but he'd Batista
in the Bahamas Thank You Nikki we're
gonna hear a lot of those stories over
the next weeks as people you know find
each other and rebuild their